hello guys and welcome to another video
so this video will contain spoilers from
the man Lauren season 3 episode 4. sorry
did in fact get Order 66 flashback scene
we have finally gotten answers on who
rescued grogu and the answer may
surprise you it turns out to be Jar Jar
Binks we're not quite but they actor who
plays him armored best and I will say he
certainly did do his best in this scene
because his acting performance in this
was absolutely incredible now this Jedi
character we've actually seen before in
a YouTube loan series Star Wars Jedi
Temple Challenge and I gotta say seen
armored best in Star Wars again was just
like Eden and Mars Bar it was just a
great delight and a really enjoyable
experience and his character is pretty
badass when he started wooed in those
two lightsabers they're just
the hype started rolling in and really
happy for Ahmad best because you know
had a little bit of a scout in the
Twitter which is not the most
recommended thing to do but a reception
for his character has been very very
positive everyone is loving his return
to Star Wars and is given so much
positive reception so seeing him get his
deserve praise it's just it's just a
really nice thing you know just like
when you get a good man or an episode
it's just a good feeling but anyway
that's about it for this video just let
me know what you thought of the sequence
in the comment section below and if you
did enjoy the video please consider
subscribing and liking thank you for
watching my friends